it is a one-of-a-kind holiday experience
complete with hundreds of elves and
lights and snow globes and a whole lot
of great festive stuff
we're talking about wonderland it's made
its debut over at area 15 today
sasha loftus gives us a look inside
it is quite the fun time here at area 15
for the opening of wanderland it's a
great way to
celebrate the start of the holiday
season while also getting a little bit
of alien fun
in there you can see behind me this is
where the trees
are located you can see some snow globes
the wonderland as you walk through
check out all the trees as well there
are performances
there is hot chocolate there is
cocktails available there are cocktails
available it's just a really great
opportunity
to just kind of bring the whole family
and stay safe
and socially distanced we're doing it
safe we're outdoors
we're distance it's timed entry so it
doesn't get too crowded
you can go into a snow globe and have a
personal dining experience just you and
your little pod talk about a bubble
literally go into a bubble as i said
wanderland kicked off today this is the
opening night it runs
every day from four to either 10 or
midnight depending on the day of the
week so
definitely worth checking out and hey
you do have a while to come see this
it is set to last through january 3rd
of 2021 so all through the holiday
season
reporting at area 15 sasha loftis 8 news
now